candid
truth what up everybody thank you for
joining us at candid truth we're gonna
talk about the truth and we're gonna get
candid with it candid truth so I've been
hearing about these fires and if you
have been a part of the truth or
Community you probably already know that
there are some theories wrapped up in it
and that this is something that's not
new we've seen this with the paradise
fires we saw this with the Maui fires we
saw this with some other fires as well
and and uh I just anytime I see stuff on
mainstream Media news I'm always looking
at it with a very skeptical eye I know
that Satan is the God of this world and
I know that there's an agenda working
through the militaries of the world the
governments of the world to unite
Humanity in a one world religion a one
world order this is all Bible prophecy
it's not a conspiracy theory that word
was created to make people look crazy
that know the truth and who believe the
Bible and so it's not crazy to look at
conspiracy theories um that's one thing
that I see come up a lot
in Christian crowds and stuff they're
like man don't get wrapped up in
conspiracy theories and this and that
look if you believe in the Bible you are
a conspiracy theorist because the Bible
says that Satan is the God of this world
that we're in a spiritual war that's all
around us that you can't see that's
working through the governments of the
world that are going to unite Humanity
that is a conspiracy and it's not a
theory it's a fact if you believe the
Bible and so this term conspiracy theory
and don't get hung up on these things
that's that's not true we are uh
Believers of Bible prophecy and if you
say what we believe according to Bible
prophecy to anyone in the world in the
secular World they will call you
conspiracy theorist I'm sorry that's
just the facts so we're just looking at
the truth we want to know the truth here
on this channel we want to look we want
to dig and investigate and look at
evidence and not just turn a blind eye
and bury our head in the sand or say I'm
not going to go there because that's
that could hurt somebody's feelings or
that's an emotional topic or whatever it
is that's how agendas like this work
false flags and all these things are
wrapped up in things that are going to
pull your heartstrings they're you know
they're kids that are getting shot at
schools and things like this they're
things that make people want to have our
freedoms taken away right I'm I'm GNA
start out with the kind of small stuff
and then get into the more Deep dive
down the rabbit hole stuff but I'll
start out with just the stuff that's
like on the news um stuff that you know
you can trust because it's on mainstream
Media news right so check this
out they're 90 years
old that they've had they've lived in
this house for
75 years and they've had the same
insurance and these insurance people
decided to cancel their fire and we're
going through this and it just happened
and they have no fire
insurance so thank you California
insurance companies
supporting residents who pay taxes and
love California and they wonder why
people leave California
right I mean this lady saying that her
parents they lost the fire Insurance on
their insurance like months before this
happened in July I think it was this
isn't a conspiracy theory this is on the
news so yeah check it out CBS news says
thousands of Los Angeles homeowners were
dropped by their insurance before the
Palisades
fire now here it says about 1, 1600
policies in Pacific Palisades were
dropped by State Farm in
July that's crazy June July August
September October November December
January six months ago so half a year
ago the State Farm dropped the fire
portion of their
insurance that seems sketchy that seems
fishy to me that's not a conspiracy
theory this is just fact so this is one
thing that makes me wonder why why would
a company do that why would a company do
that unless they knew
somehow that there were going to be many
homes catching on
fire I'm not saying they did but it just
seems like a red flag right th if this
was any other situation people would be
getting arrested for this like you
dropping claims when okay so if I took
on a fire Insurance claim on my home and
6 months later my home burns down
they're going to investigate that
they're going to want to try and prove
that I burnt my own home down to get
fire insurance money right this is part
of investigating I don't know why when
it comes to mainstream Media news and
the the official story we're just
supposed to swallow it up and we're not
supposed to investigate don't look into
it no no that's that's crazy don't do
that that's that's harmful to do that is
what they say and then we also see that
it says says why did LA defund its fire
department last year two days ago this
this article was two days ago yes Los
Angeles cut
$17.6 million from the fire department's
budget are you kidding
me
what what this is like recipe for
disaster okay there's Fire coming uh we
need six months we need to drop the fire
insurance we need to cut the budget on
the fire
department and and somehow they were out
of water what happened to California's
water supply during the water fire
during the
wildfires
news Newsom calls for investigation into
Wildfire water
supply I saw a video of firefighters not
able to get water from their fire truck
the fire engine and they're like or
through the hose anyway and they're
filling up purses and throwing the water
purse by purse in a dumpster to try and
put out a dumpster fire which doesn't
seem that important in the big scheme of
things but uh there are some strange
things here so insurance claims dropped
fire department defunded and no water
ironically enough coincidentally
enough then uh there's all the
predictive programming right why is Los
Angeles targeted for Destruction so
often in Hollywood movies and so this is
just a post um talking about that they
noticed that there's a lot of Hollywood
this isn't even recent this was asked
nine years ago and it says one of my
favorite types of films are the ones
where some form of cataclysm occurs
morbid I know but one thing I have
noticed in many films is the destruction
of the city of Los Angeles sometimes
destroyed by itself and sometimes
destroyed alongside other cities and it
says Al aside from the obvious battle
Los Angeles there are massive
earthquakes such as the San Andreas 2012
in earlier earthquake film Alien Attack
aside from the example before earlier in
the original War of the Worlds volcanic
eruption in a movie Volcano I guess
meteor meteorolog
meteorological events destruction by
tornadoes in The Day After Tomorrow
nuclear war and the Miracle Mile
at least one of the Terminator films
that's true like La gets destroyed so
many times and we know in the truth or
community that predictive programming is
real it's man everything down to the
aliens down to so many things that we've
seen the Twin Towers all that stuff was
predicted over and over and over again
and it came true and The Simpsons are
Infamous for doing it and so when we
look at these movies like this that are
predictive programming there's a movie
called Escape From LA and it says snake
is back that's interesting right snake
who is the snake we know that the snake
is Satan that dragon and notice the one
eye symbolism you see uh to the left of
his head the fires on the palm trees and
it is escape from LA and notice his name
is snake the snake is back Satan is back
right and here's another flyer and you
can clearly see La is on fire and
there's nothing but silhouettes of palm
trees La is on fire and it says nobody
gets that alive until now why because if
you've ever seen the movie Snake is the
hero maybe he's like an
anti-hero but this is the same Gnostic
Gospel we see in these movies all the
time right who's the hero Satan's the
hero who's the villain God's the villain
so let's look at the plot does it fit
that same gnostic gospel that so many
movies uh fulfill and snake snake is the
good guy so here's what the movie plot
is it says in 2013 this is when it's
based in 2013 the United States
president is ex exiling all citizens who
don't conform to his hyper conservative
views okay would God be considered
someone that has hyper conservative
views yes okay so here's this Le who's
got these hyper conservative views and
if you don't follow those rules you get
exiled that's totally biblical right um
views to Los Angeles so you get exiled
to Los Angeles ironically Los Angeles is
like going to hell I guess um which
became an island after a huge earthquake
but when the president's daughter nabs
The Detonator to her dad's apocalyptic
weapon okay this is the same kind of
thing we see in so many movies that it's
the the the Lord the president the god
whoever it is it's always his daughter
right or some woman because in
gnosticism it's Sophia Sophia was the
serpent in the garden that said if you
eat this fruit your eyes will be open
you'll become like God you'll be able to
evolve to a higher state of being and so
in the movie smallfoot there was the
stonekeeper and it was his daughter that
called him out and said he was a liar
and uh The Lego Movie there was Lucy she
was the one telling him you need to wake
up you need to break the rules it's
always about breaking the rules right
okay so her dad has an apocalyptic
weapon the apocalypse right that's
biblical an apocalyptic weapon so a
president who has hyper conservative
views or laws and he's got an
apocalyptic weapon this is God and and
she sneaks into LA to be with the rebel
leader that she loves so the the
president's daughter is in love with a
rebel leader that's Satan and this
always happens too because there's
that's always the the main character the
hero is Satan it says the government
Taps Commando turned crook snake so
snake is the he he was a crook wait a
minute it says the government Taps
Commando turn crook snake piskin to
retrieve the young woman and if he
doesn't succeed quickly he'll be
executed so okay he's a prisoner and
he's sent on a mission by the government
to retrieve the president's daughter and
he's snake but you if you watch the
movie you'll see that he is a good guy
he's like an
anti-hero so check this out this is the
president's daughter her name is Utopia
what is a Utopia Utopia is a paradise a
perfect world
right and it says Utopia is the daughter
of President Adam the president's name
is Adam his daughter's name is Utopia
and the first lady Eve are you kidding
me this is not a stretch this is right
in your face Adam and Eve their daughter
Utopia after her sister
Eden Eden committed suicide okay so when
Adam and Eve ate of that fruit Paradise
was lost Eden was gone Eden committed
suicide if you will she retreated into a
virtual reality for days at a time while
in virtual
reality quvo Jones somehow hacked into
the virtual reality database most likely
with the help of test tube
quvo convinces Utopia so he convinces
the daughter that her father is an evil
Tyrant who will stop at nothing to keep
his power she quickly falls in love with
him thinking that he will that he is a
freedom fighter on the side of
righteousness okay so okay let me
continue quvo tells her to steal the
black box which controls the sword of De
Deal's satellite armed with EMP to
permanently black out any part of Earth
they are targeted believing that quvo
I'm probably butchering that name
quvo is fighting for for all those
oppressed by her father's corrupt regime
she helps him by stealing the Black Box
okay so you have this guy who is the the
rebel leader who's convincing the
daughter of the president who's got
these conservative views that he's not a
good guy he's a tyrant in fact and she
falls in love with that Rebel leader
this is the total Gnostic message over
and over again and the fact that it's
president Adam first first lady Eve
uh daughter named Eden daughter named
Utopia it's just right in your
face so here is uh a little clip from
the movie check it out failure to obey
these rules will result in immediate
loss of citizenship and deportation to
the island of Los
Angeles your rules really begin to annoy
me so man the Hollywood does nothing
original there's nothing original in
Hollywood it's the same movie over and
over and over this movie came came out
in like
1996 and it's saying all these rules if
you don't follow the rules you will be
kicked out and he's like I'm sick of
your rules the oneeyed snake is telling
you I'm sick of your rules I kind of
want to hear it again just to hear what
he said failure to obey these rules will
result in immediate loss of citizenship
and deportation to the island of Los
Angeles loss of citizenship you will not
be a citizen of Heaven if you don't keep
the rules but it's always painted in a
negative way in Hollywood over and over
and over again the same movie every
every time so here here's another
scene thank God almighty thank God
Almighty Welcome Back
Sir so you hear those words thank God
Almighty he's the the bad guy the
president get her out of here Daddy
that's his own daughter take her to the
chair now listen to those words for he
so loved his
country he gave his only seditious
child do you hear him quoting scripture
this is the villain the villain of the
movie is quoting scripture of course
it's twisted a little bit but it's
saying w why would anybody say that for
one he ran out he's like oh God almighty
God almighty I'm so glad you're alive
and then his daughter comes out and he
says get rid of her take her to the
electric chair and then he says for for
the president so Lov the nation that he
gave his only corrupt daughter or
something like that he's quoting
scripture why is it always the villain
that's quoting scripture this is not a
coincidence this is not some stretch
this is this is what it is this is the
facts when you see this pattern over and
over and over again it's no longer
coincidence there's an agenda to make
people hate Christians to make people
hate God to make people side with Satan
because Satan knows that there is a war
coming he knows that when Christ returns
it's over and he's trying to take as
many people with him as he can he's
trying to make as many people side with
him in a war against Christ when Christ
returns and so he's using brainwashing
propaganda over and over and over again
and it's working when you look around
the world the world is so wicked and I
think that the media has a huge role in
it so the scene continues you got to
smoke the United States is the no
smoking Nation no smoking no drinking no
drugs no women unless of course you're
married no guns no foul language no red
meat Land of the
Free you see that so he asked for a
smoke you got to smoke and he goes this
is a no smoking Nation no drinking
Nation no women unless you're married no
red
meat are you kidding me this is
heaven and he's
like Land of the Free like he hates it
he hates that he can't have a smoke he
hates that he can't sin he can't
fornicate he can't eat animals he can't
smoke and drink but that's heaven and
it's painting it in this like negative
light so that the viewer is like I hate
this guy this guy who has all these
rules yeah that's not freedom but it is
freedom true Freedom comes from the law
of Liberty God says calls it his law of
Liberty because his laws are the law of
love and when you love your neighbor and
you love God that's true Freedom
enslavement comes from being enslaved to
the bondage of sin but God is going to
set us free from that he can set you
free now from that all right so let's
continue
I now
render this Final
Solution welcome to your very own map to
the Stars sure we all know the big one
wiped out the entertainment industry
here in LA but the Glamour and
excitement of Hollywood is still
alive very
funny yeah I just think that's
interesting that it said the the big one
wiped out Hollywood but you know the
entertainment is still alive so this
movie is predicting that Hollywood would
be
destroyed but that's the president he's
setting up this live feed and there's
gonna be a camera on him and he's gonna
give a he's goingon to give a
speech but he wants to kill snake so
think about this biblically you got the
president God you got the snake Satan
and he wants to destroy the snake so
that he can have a perfect world with
all these hyper conservative rules but
the movie paints it all in a negative
light that's how Satan does he takes the
truth and he twists it 99% truth is not
truth anymore that's how Satan deceives
the world he's deceiving the World by
giving you deception and deception is
not an outright lie it's a twisted truth
it's 99% truth so he's just said that
the radio just came on and said uh you
know the big one got rid of Hollywood
but entertainment is still here this is
this is predictive programming look two
days ago fire crews make progress on
Sunset fire in Hollywood Hills Hollywood
Hills is on fire Hollywood Hills is is
destroyed now here we go again I hope it
was worth it for now you are going to
die everybody does kill him sir we're
still broadcasting good let them
watch do it
do it on my
command
fire so notice they're broadcasting I I
I chopped this up for copyright purposes
but they're they're saying that they're
broadcasting worldwide the whole world
is seeing the president and he's saying
kill him and they turn the cameras
around and she she says hey we're still
rolling he says good let him watch so
think about that the whole world is
getting to see God kill the serpent is
that
biblical right here in Ezekiel 28:1
18-19 it says I will destroy thee Oh
covering cherub from the midst of the
stones of fire thine heart was lifted up
because of thy Beauty thy Hast corrupted
thy wisdom by reason of thy brightness I
will cast thee to the ground I will lay
thee before kings that they may behold
thee so God is going to lay Satan before
everyone the kings of the Earth the
people of the earth and everyone's going
to get to see the destruction of Satan
because of what he's been doing causing
chaos in this whole world for these
Generations upon
Generations it continues and it says
therefore I will bring a fire from the
midst of thee it shall devour thee and I
will bring thee to ashes upon the Earth
in the sight of all them that behold
thee all they that Know Thee among the
people shall be astonished at thee Thou
shalt be a terror and never shalt thou
be anymore Satan's going to be destroyed
and turned to ashes and be no more
Hallelujah you know how there's so many
people out there that believe that the
destruction of the or the the punishment
for the wicked is an everlasting
eternity and fire oh endless that's not
the god of love the god of love is I'm
going to destroy wickedness and get it
out of here so that there's never sin in
this world again there'll be no more
pain no more sorrow for all eternity a
promise that would be a lie if he was
eternally burning your family and
friends who didn't know him even Satan
the creator of all this sin is going to
be turned to ashes and become no
more so the scene continues so what are
you going to do
disappear types in six
66 that's crazy he's entered the world
code the world code is 666 sir that'll
shut down the entire planet don't do it
[Music]
snake what are we seeing here what is in
the picture right now so snake just
typed
666 pressed the button and lasers from
space begin to shoot down at the planet
Earth
H I just think that's really interesting
in light of the fires that we've seen
over the years and what people have
actually caught on video they're saying
hey these fires aren't a normal fire
something started these
fires this is Robocop 1987 check this
out good evening I'm Jess Perkins with
Casey Wong top story Santa Barbara
10,000 acres of wooded residential land
were scorched in an instant when a laser
cannon aboard the Strategic Defense
peace platform misfired today during
routine startup tests Casey yes it was a
day of M for the families of 113 people
known dead at this hour among them two
former United States presidents who had
retired in the Santa Barbara area a day
of morning for a country Santa Barbara
is
California so RoboCop in 1987 predicted
lasers from space accidentally firing
and harming people thousands people I
think it said or maybe a couple hundred
people in
California so again we see lasers in
space shooting California I think that's
interesting check out these videos
people we are all equipped with phones
now that have cameras on them and a lot
of things get caught on camera that
probably shouldn't have been captured
and then we can put that on the internet
and blasted out to the world and there
are these fact Checkers out there that
are trying to shut down everything
there's you know uh YouTube and Facebook
they're trying to shut down anything
that's
misinformation or uh fake news and so
there's all this censorship out there I
remember when YouTube was like not
censored except for like if it was uh
animal abuse or drug use or something
like that but there was a time when you
could actually look up conspiracy
theories on YouTube and actually find a
lot of results now it's so censored that
you can't find anything even Google you
have to go to duck ducko or something
now this video is on Loop that's why it
keeps going that's not a whole that's
not like continuing lasers but this guy
was capturing some what appears to be
lasers shooting these trees and Sparks
are coming
out and then there's this type of stuff
and and I'm not sure that all of this is
from California but this is the type of
stuff that people have been seeing
during these fires in Cal Paradise Maui
and now in
La so what is starting these thing now
does this sound sci-fi this is just like
movie stuff
right Sci-Fi movies is it
real well let's check it out this
project known as Kina is being developed
at Russia's Chona facility renowned for
its Advanced Optical Technologies the
first trace of this project surfaced in
2002 when Kina was mentioned in a
doctoral thesis as the name of a study
commissioned by the Russian Ministry of
Defense Kina has actually evolved into a
space weapon a sophisticated attack
system hidden under the guise of
scientific research three independent
sources we've consulted have provided
clear evidence of the Project's shift
toward military purposes
first in January 2014 a publicly
available Bank guarantee document
revealed that Kina was designed to
create a system for counteracting the
functions of satellite photonic systems
using solid state lasers combined with
adaptive Optical transmission reception
system a year later in 2017 another
document surfaced describing Kina as a
space security complex a term also used
for the borov vesik anti-satellite
system a project believed to be
related finally in the 2013 annual
report by npks one of the rare online
reports the organization acknowledged
its involvement in developing a laser
system for photonic
Warfare a laser system for Warfare this
is not sci-fi this is reality has been
for many years I have I've always liked
to watch those Discovery Channels like
futuristic uh technology and futuristic
weapons and all that stuff way before I
was even awake to any of this stuff and
this stuff's been talked about for a
while here's another
clip from Discovery Channel America is
developing three new laser weapon
systems capable of taking out anything
in their path and they do it at the
speed of
light first up is the Airborne laser
it's designed to shoot down
intercontinental ballistic missiles from
a jumbo
jet next is the close com version called
the advanced tactical laser carried on
much smaller aircraft like the latest
Joint Strike fighter planes the ATL is
every bit as deadly taking out air and
ground targets with Incredible stealth
and last but not least the Marine Corps
is now testing a Mobile land system
called the Tactical high energy laser it
will cut down and Destroy incoming enemy
missiles this is crazy I mean this isn't
Star Wars anymore this is real life life
and now we have a US space force since
2019 we have lasers that can shoot
satellites and all these things are what
they're saying and you know I don't want
to get into the whole cosmology issues
here
but um yeah we're talking about we're
living in a time where we're shooting
lasers out into the
atmosphere
and according to revelation we are going
to go to war with Christ when Christ
returns it says three unclean spirits
like frogs think about what alien gravs
look like for one three unclean spirits
like frogs are going to unite the
militaries of the world to battle
against the second coming of Christ and
now we have a space force where we're
shooting weapons towards the heavens we
have these laser weapons that they're
showing you
exist and and UFOs everywhere they call
them uaps look when the news is talking
about drun drones quote unquote drones
they're not drones just because that's
the terminology they keep using they're
trying to desensitize you to having
things flying around in the sky think
about all these movies uh the minseries
V and some of the other movies where the
UFOs they just hover over the cities for
weeks and they're and they don't harm
anybody so people just get back to
normal life and they're like yeah
they're up there but they haven't done
anything so I guess they're not going to
it's to get you instead of okay
when War of the Worlds pretty sure it's
War of the World when that radio show
came on War of the World sounded like a
real life newscast was saying oh the UFO
just landed and the aliens coming out
he's hideous people killed themselves
people committed suicide because they
didn't want to face an alien race they
didn't want to be captured and
potentially tortured by these beings and
they killed themselves so whether that
was a scop or
not the the powers that be could take
that information of what happened and
know how people are going to respond
that there's going to be panic and Chaos
if quote unquote aliens just reveal
themselves so they're they're doing this
stuff where there's things in the sky
and I I believe some of it's military
and some of it is Supernatural and it's
just going on in the
sky and there the military is telling us
well we don't know what it is it's not
ours and it's not foreign but don't
worry they're bevent
benevolent they're not malevolent
they're not malicious so you know don't
worry about it that makes no sense no
logical sense at all to I don't know
what that is but it's okay so they're
getting you immune to getting you used
to these things Spiritual Beings demons
Fallen Angels being in our skies and to
just go on with life as usual and soon
there will be disclosure soon there will
be these unclean spirits like frogs
uniting the militaries of the world
together soon there will be Miracle
working demons like the Bible says that
will deceive millions of people because
Satan is going to come as an angel of
Light he's going to come as the cosmic
Christ and say I am Christ I am here I
can get rid of climate change I can get
rid of cancer I can get rid of the
pandemics I can heal I
can cure world
hunger and how are you going to look at
that supernatural being something we've
never seen in our life and say this is a
demonic deception people will lock you
up they'll say you are the problem you
you are a Discord and our perfect
Utopia and lock you up and so that's
prophetically what's coming
and I want you to check out this video
clip it's it's almost four minutes long
but man it just shows you if you think
that this is really out there this
whole lasers directed energy weapons
they're called if you just think it's
totally out there this video is going to
show you some
proof some evidence that this is not
natural these are not natural like
forest fires check this out the recent
fires in California Australia and now
Hawaii are unlike anything we've ever
seen
before they are being called forest
fires and wildfires but they are clearly
something very different these fires are
burning homes into a white powdery Ash
footprint while often leaving the
surrounding green trees and shrubs
practically
untouched in extreme cases forest fires
can reach temperatures up to 1500° F and
the melting point of alumin aluminum is
1220 de F so it is possible for an
extreme forest fire to melt aluminum but
there are cars with puddles of melted
aluminum that were clearly not in the
Wildfire area and melted glass which has
a melting point around 2500° F these are
unexplained anomalies in the California
fires of 2018 cars were randomly
bursting into flames on the freeway with
no surrounding
fires we've seen these same anomalies in
New York City on September 11th 2001
cars completely burned out with no
explanation in Hoi these unnatural fires
spared the homes of the rich while
burning the native homes of the working
class with Precision these fires
destroyed the most envied High valued
areas of Maui for decades directed
energy weapons have been classified but
they have been on the public record for
several years now directed energy
weapons known as Do's have the ability
to burn homes with this sort of
precision but in order to be this
precise the area would have to be mapped
out in January of this year Green Lasers
were seen over Hawaii which could best
be described as a geospatial array for
mapping Terrain
we have seen that among the ashy ruins
there are blue colored objects that have
somehow survived the
devastation blue
cars blue
umbrellas a blue
boat blue
Planters videos online are going viral
that show how lasers can easily burn
through certain colored objects but
objects that are colored blue remain
unharmed
directed energy weapons include lasers
millimeter wave and microwave they are
all based on light frequencies and
different wavelengths of light affect
colors differently for example in laser
tattoo removal different wavelengths are
used for removing different colors and
this is because color is a quality of
light each color has its own frequency
interestingly enough the frequency of
the color blue is
6.66 I'm sure plenty of you have seen
these videos that have been coming out
of Maui a vehicle is literally melting
onto the street these specifically are
from Jeff signis on Tik
Tok like I said the aluminum is
literally melting out of the vehicles
and the melting point for aluminum is
1220 de fah um that's just crazy because
as you can see in this next video none
of the asphal has melted along with this
and you would expect that to happen in
fires that are reaching over 1220 de the
melting point of asphalt is 343 de
Fahrenheit so make that make
sense I'm seeing in the chat some people
are skeptical of the blue thing and uh
also that blue is the color of the law
blue is the the one color that was
removed from the rainbow blue is the
color of the Ten Commandments and 666 is
the temperature or the frequency of
these lasers crazy especially since
snake pressed 666 and lasers came from
the sky and hit
La
coincidence I don't think so we're going
to look at some of that blue stuff
though after we look at these uh
scriptures here Revelation 13:12 says
and he in parenthesis I put this the
second beast which is America if you
understand Bible prophecy the first
Beast is Rome and the second beast is
America and they're going to join forces
America is GNA make an image unto the
first Beast which is Rome and he the
second beast America exercises all the
power of the first Beast Rome before him
and he causes the Earth and them which
dwell therein to worship the first Beast
so America is going to cause the whole
world World To Worship Rome whose deadly
wound was healed healed we know that
Rome fell a long time ago and clearly
that that wound has been healed when all
the leaders of the world every American
president goes over there kisses the
hand of the Pope shakes the hand of the
Pope why what does America have to do
with Rome what does all these leaders
have to do with Rome why are they going
over there to see some religious leader
and kiss his hand because it's all Bible
prophecy Rome is the Beast the first
Beast it goes on Revelation 13:13 says
and he doeth great wonders so that he
make fire come down from heaven on the
earth in the sight of men are we living
in Bible prophecy do we believe Bible
prophecy that the second beast America
is going to have power to bring down
fire from the sky in the sight of men
and burn up
cities I believe we're seeing it right
now I believe we're living in the last
days I believe we're seeing it right
now here's the
video how
lasers there was something blue they
didn't want to burn did not burn in
Flames same as The Blue Umbrella laser
weap be program for different
wavelengths
[Music]
wow here's another example so this is
one of those uh flashlights that can
burn
things 7.5 watt
laser and if he leaves it there on the
paint long enough you'll start to see
smoke and Embers right
there and then he moves to the other
color and he's starting to get the smoke
and
[Music]
Embers and now he's going to move to the
blue on the far
left and no
effect because we're talking about
frequencies and somehow the frequencies
have to do with color I'm not saying and
I understand it I'm not a scientist a a
physicist a chemist any of that but
there's been multiple tests so here's a
laser on some paint earlier we saw a
laser on fabric and now here's a laser
on even balloons and
go now you may notice there are some
survivors here the blue
one so he the the laser doesn't pop the
blue this video is long it's like 4
minutes long and that balloon never pops
so blue balloon blue fabric blue paint
on a paint stir
stick is not affected by a
laser and so if you see look we're just
Gathering evidence we're looking at
evidence okay the evidence shows lasers
don't affect blue things whether it's
fabric rubber or paint
all right that we know that that's some
good evidence to have how does it help
us well let's look at all these fire
sites where the trees are literally
still green and untouched but the house
is literally ashes there's no
refrigerator there's no laundry machine
there's nothing metal there's not even a
chimney it is Rubble but right next to
it are green trees and green grass that
should make you question things and then
you start to see blue umbrellas blue
cars blue boats blue uh flower pots that
should make you think a little bit more
okay if houses are demolished but the
things next to it aren't that seems like
pinpoint
accuracy and what is pinpointed that
doesn't affect blue
lasers so I mean this is this is crazy
I'm
not I'm not reaching I'm not grasping at
straws I'm putting together evidence and
this is where the evidence leads for
me this is
[Music]
China China has a lot of blue roofs I'm
not sure
[Music]
that just that may just be coincidence I
don't know I I read blue roofs are
cheaper or something I don't know I
don't know what to believe I'm just
we're just looking at stuff we're
looking at evidence here so Revelation
said and he deceiveth them that dwell on
the Earth by means of those Miracles
which he had power to do in the sight of
the Beast saying to them that dwell on
the earth that they should make an image
of the Beast which had the wound by the
deadly By The Sword and live so this is
America is saying that all the world
should make an image to the first Beast
which is Rome NBC news says military
wants the weather on its side space.com
this year's horrid hurricane season has
scientists
associated with the military Wonder ing
about ways to improve predictions and
even control
storms is this a conspiracy theory look
this is mainstream Media news this was
2005 oh what does this say even flooding
around with fog and clouds can deny or
create
concealment whichever weather
manipulation does the needed
job it says in this regard nanot
technology could be utilized to create
clouds of tiny smart
particles this is interesting in light
of the strange fog that's been seen all
over the world atmospherically buoyant
these Ultra small computer particles
could navigate themselves to block
Optical sensors alternatively they might
be used to provide an atmospheric
electrical potential difference a
precise way to aim and time lightning
strikes over the enemy's head and
thereby concoct Thunderbolts on
demand are you hearing this like they
have the technology with
nanotechnology to control the weather
control where Lightning goes and then it
says perhaps that's too far out for some
but some blue sky thinkers have already
looked into these and other scenarios in
weather as a force multiplier owning the
weather in 2025 a research paper written
by a serson team of Military Officers
and presented in
1996 as part of a larger study dubbed
Air Force 2025 so in 1996 the same year
that escape from La came
out Military seven Military Officers put
this article together put this thing
together a written paper
called owning the weather in
2025 and you can find it here this is uh
apps.
d.m you see it up at the top there um
and this is it weather as a force
multiplier owning the weather in 2025 a
research paper presented to Air Force
2025 August
1996 this is now Declassified
information
when you look at the cont the
contents you'll see a global Weather
Network it says why do you why do we
want to mess with the weather fog right
there fog storms explorations of near
space artificial weather on page 27 so
fog is page
16 let's look at that real quick there's
some illustrations and everything in
here fog page 16 fog in general
successful fog decip requires some type
of heating or seating process which
technique which technique works best
depending on the type of fog encountered
so they're telling you they can they can
create fog and then it said 27 I wanted
to see what that said look at these
pictures this is
crazy this is harp
which is also Declassified now
artificial weather While most weather
modification efforts rely on the
existence of certain pre-existing
conditions it may be possible to produce
some weather effects artificially
regardless of pre-existing conditions
for instance virtual weather could be
created by influencing the weather
information received by an end user I'm
not going to read all this this is kind
of getting off topic I just think it's
interesting that in 1996 they're writing
about controlling the weather in
2025 with things such as harp and lasers
and all this stuff and you got these
fires that are coming why though that's
the question
why why burn places down that's the big
question right everybody want to know
why would you do that especially the
government don't you want to take care
of your people why would you burn your
own people down that's the big question
look at
this and Information Technology agency
city of Los
Angeles what is it this is
it.
city.gov and this is all talking about
smart La
2028 so they want to make smart cities
by 2028 they want cities to be smart
cities and this specifically is about
La isn't that coincidental we live in a
world full of urban challenges from
racial Injustice that impacts our
minority populations to natural
disasters that threaten safety and
property to environmental changes that
affect the very water we drink and the
air we breathe to address these blah
blah blah we want to make smart cities
this is why the city of Los Angeles
strives to be a smart city in 2019 the
city of Los Angeles Information
Technology agency convened its smart
City committee how do you turn a city
that already exists into a smart
city I think it's ironic and very
coincidental that the city that they
want to turn into a smart city in three
years from now is now burned to the
ground and it's
gone isn't that interesting here it is
smart La this is this is part of the
same website just look up smart La
2028 and um there's this whole document
here where it talks about Digital
Services
governance smart cities are
multifaceted there's some interesting
things in here when I was reading
through
it how to make a smarter
City Smart City
infrastructure physical technology used
to deliver Smart City Technologies to
Residents businesses and visitors
specifically focused on technology in
the rights of way used to deliver
services in the cityscape Smart City
Smart City
see INF infrastructure physical
technology so to have a smart City
infrastructure you would have to start
from ground zero right from the ground
up and here's a timeline I mean they got
2020 2021
2022 and right here in the middle of
2024 and 2025 it says says expand
environmental sensors across La install
environmental sensors to inform REM
remediation of Environmental Quality
concerns noise
air uh noise and air quality by
interesting right here between 2023 and
2024 it says install 10,000 public
electric vehicle Chargers to promote
smart Alternative Energy us use by
2024 so who's in control of this stuff
haachi haachi is the ones who are doing
the smart cities where is Hatachi doing
smart cities and isn't it really
interesting I just said where is Hitachi
building smart cities and it says Maui
Hawaii you mean the place that got
burned up now it's a smart City H and
yet there's a whole document saying they
want to turn La into a smart city by
2028 and coincidentally it's
gone it's
leveled the stage is set for them to
build their Smart City now so yeah I
just think it's really interesting that
Maui burned up and now it's a smart city
of all the places in the world it just
makes me think of Biden's saying to
build back better
right you can't build back unless
something's gone right so it just seems
ironic that places are burning up and
they're being built back better this is
order out of chaos this is what they do
they they cause the problem and give the
solution and they're like look and it's
this big heartwarming thing like we're
gonna build back better we're gonna come
back better than before you'll see watch
us and they're building your
prison the green dragon is what they
call this green movement it sounds
beautiful to have natural resources and
all these things but there's an agenda
behind all this there's there's places
there's a map Agenda 21 can't remember
but there's Maps where there are no
people zones zones for no
people and this whole system is bringing
us into the singularity movement where
every person is connected into the
internet we are all one entity of a hive
mind and they have control over
everything every phone every camera
every microphone everything's already
tapped as it is but imagine a smart
city this is worldwide enslavement
worldwide control perfect for the Beast
to bring about his one world religion
the mark of the beast system the mark of
the beast is not a microchip ship or a
tattoo people get so hung up on the one
verse that says you can't buy or sell
without the Mark it's true if you don't
take the mark of worship you will not be
able to buy or sell or trade just like
it also says you will be thrown in
prison and it says you'll be
beheaded but the mark of the beast is
not a form of currency it's a form of
worship and there's forms of punishment
that happen to those who do not worship
according to the Beast system
and how are they going to enforce that
forced worship with technology social
credit scores checkins did you check in
to the World Church we didn't see knock
on your door it seems like you missed
church last Sunday uh was there a reason
were you sick taking tabs on everything
you do and we're doing it willfully
check-ins how many times have you went
to a restaurant and it says hey if you
check in you'll get 10% off your order
and by checking in it's going to your
social media and showing everybody that
you were eating at that Mexican
restaurant and that gives them promotion
and it gives you a discount but they're
getting you used to the idea of of tab
keeping tabs of wherever you're at this
is where I'm at I'm checking the box I
went to church I'm look I'm taking a
selfie this is creepy now this is a
mysterious video I don't know where it
came
from but
this is like I I think that this whole
tiny home fad was to get us used to
prison cells honestly that sounds like a
joke I'm not
joking tiny homes where I get it you
don't need a huge house I would never
want a mansion I don't have any need for
that but to make you getting used to
living in one room and saying oh it's
cool it's Trinity they're charging as
much for a a tiny home as some
houses look at that I mean that is a
gimmick if I've ever heard
one they're getting you used to living
in a prison cell check this
out like I said I don't know where this
is but what in the world is
this look at these tiny homes bars on
the
Windows it looks like they got a
charging station on the
front these are just concrete
slabs what is
this dude does this not freak you out
like they are building these I don't
know if this is a smart city I don't
know what this is but they are building
our camps our new home look none of this
is for
here we this is to to show that the
Bible is true the Bible predicted it
prophecy is coming true we're living in
the last days right now where there's
literally the the aliens the Frog likee
beings that are going to unite the
militaries of the world we have the
space force we have the lasers we have
the entities that are flying around in
the skies we have the One World
Government the United Nations that are
rounding up all the militaries of the
world to begin to prepare to fight
against Christ we have have the whole
infrastructure set up of worldwide
enslavement and the last clip
here this is probably as freaky as it
gets what is that machine
for look this is not a scene of a movie
or something now I don't know exactly
what China is doing here but it does
look awfully close to the energetically
autonomous tactical robot aka the eater
bot as the robot could Forge from
biomass to fuel itself was canceled in
2022 as rumors speculated it could or
would ingest humans but it looks like
China is right back on top of it and
maybe this bot has a different function
but just like when Boston Dynamics
demoed their robot dogs dancing China
went straight into using them to enforce
lockdown restrictions all right that's
crazy to enforce lockdown restriction
China used robots to enforce lockdown
restrictions
and now they're building machines that
with a conveyor belt that picks up dead
bodies that stuff that he was reading
said that the machines actually feed on
the biow waste the machines are fueled
by human dead
bodies like this is a sci-fi movie if
I've ever seen one soilent green comes
to mind if you've ever seen that this is
this is the world we're living
in I'm only showing you these jarring
truths because I want people to wake up
I want Christians to stop living one
foot in the world one foot in the church
and oh they've been saying Jesus has com
in my whole life and even in the Bible
days we got a long time look I was
deceived I was a Christian for eight and
a half years and had no fruit I was a
fornicating weed smoking alcoholic
rapper that was my life as a Christian
for eight and a half years because I
wasn't in God's word I didn't know the
time that we were living in I thought we
had all the time in the world I thought
I didn't understand that I had to be
become a new creature that my life had
to change that I had to repent that I
had to follow God's Commandments I
didn't understand those things and I
want Christians to know that because
right now there are so the the biggest
denomination in the world is the
Catholic church and the next
denomination that would be the mega
churches that you see on TV that when
when you ask any person on the street
what do you think of when you think of
Christianity it's either going to be
Roman Catholicism or mega churches both
of them are false so the majority of the
Christian World Is Lost Jesus says in
that day many will say many he didn't
say a couple many will say Lord Lord
they're calling him Lord didn't we do
all these things in your name and he
says depart from me I never knew you you
workers of
lawlessness it's the fact that they
didn't obey him he said why do you call
me Lord and do not the things that I
tell you why do we that's a good
question why do we call him oh yeah he's
my Lord he's my God he's my master but
you don't obey
him you can't even by definition call
somebody your Lord and Master if you
don't obey them he says if you love me
keep my Commandments you know why
because his Commandments are the way to
life if all this has made you think the
mark of the beast is coming good
Revelation 13:15 says and he had power
to give life unto the image of the Beast
that the image of the Beast should both
speak and cause that as many as would
not worship the image of the Beast
should be killed so we know that this
Beast system is literally going to kill
people if they don't worship the image
of the Beast and I believe that's why
there's all the police state there's all
the conveyor belts that are
sucking up dead bodies or all the the
prison infrastructure that's being built
is because of this system right here the
Beast system and I believe that there's
going to be a lot of death and
Carnage but how do we overcome the mark
of the beast Revelation 12:17 says and
the dragon was wroth with the woman the
church and went to make war with the
remnant I'm talking a small portion of
the
Church of her seed which keep the
Commandments of God God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ that sounds
like our day that there's only a Remnant
a small portion of the church that keep
God's
Commandments you know what I I think if
you ask most Christians do you keep the
Commandments they'd say yeah to the best
of my ability I don't take the lord's
name in vain and I don't have any other
gods before him I don't commit adultery
my wife I don't I don't lie I don't
steal you know I don't murder people but
the fourth Commandment is the one that
everyone has a a problem with like no no
nailed to the cross no it's the fourth
Commandment I even hear Christians say
it's the Ten Commandments not the 10
suggestions well except for that fourth
one that's really a suggestion
right every
commandment is based on
works right people like to say if you
keep the Sabbath that you're you're
legalist you're trying to earn your
salvation you're trying to work your way
to heaven the Sabbath is the only
Commandment that is not works it's rest
it's the opposite of Works don't work
your slaves don't work yourself don't
work your animals it's opposite of
works and what is it based on
relationship that's what salvation is a
relationship with Jesus Christ and the
only Commandment that has to do with
relationship is the time spent with God
dedicate 24 hours to spending time with
God Friday Sunset to sa Sabbath Saturday
Sunset the seventh
day and and there's going to be people
that fight against that and I don't know
why why would you fight against spending
time with the one you love if your wife
said I I feel like our relationship is
starting to dwindle can we spend each
Saturday night together and if you say
no way don't put me under that bondage
how would your wife feel you would break
her heart it would shatter her heart
this is the same way God feels he gave
us the very life we have he's giving us
eternal life and all he wants all he's
asking is 24 hours of our time you can
work six days a week but on this day
spend it with
me Revelation 14:12 here is the patience
of the saint here are they that keep the
Commandments of God and have the faith
of Jesus people think the Commandments
are done away with
that we're not based on our works but
the Revelation literally says that I
know your works and your reward comes
with
me Revelation 22:14 says blessed are
they that do his Commandments that they
may have right to the tree of life and
may enter into the
city this is what it's all
about first you have to believe with
your forehead the beliefs of your mind
and then you have to have works the
fruit Jesus says you will know them by
their fruit not because they call
themselves a Christian not because they
go to church or read their Bible but
because they obey him if you love me
keep my
Commandments I hope this video was eye
opening for you there's a lot of crazy
stuff going in our world right now and
I'm just looking at evidence I'm this is
for educational or entertainment
purposes only but do your own research
that's what all this is about the candid
truth it's cool to use your brain if you
would like to support this ministry you
can do so through cash app through vinmo
through zel you can go to candid
truth.org and click a a button there
that says donate and you'll see an
option for PayPal we can't do this
without you my wife and I stepped away
from a full-time job to do this ministry
and God has been providing each month
and it's because of people like you and
we thank you we love you we can't do
this without you if you would like to
buy a t-shirt we have a shop and we get
like $5 for these shirts that are sold
that we designed and they're all about
scripture they're all about using your
brain and it's cool to be smart because
Hollywood wants to make you think it's
uncool to be smart there's a
reason because dumb people are easier to
enslave right so let's break free from
this enslavement that's happening let's
surrender Our Lives to God every single
day let's pick up our cross daily and
follow him the King of Kings the Lord of
lords he's coming soon if you believe it
give this video a thumbs up if you're
new to this Channel please click
subscribe and the notification Bell so
you don't miss a video and we'll see you
next time on candid truth I love you
guys